Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch. Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch. Ich bin ein ganz guter Mensch.
Achso, hallo. Ich bin schon fertig mit meinem Informatikstudium und bin jetzt derzeit am Promovieren. Ah, deswegen.
Haben Sie nicht genötigt, einen Patent zu machen?
Nein, also Gott sei Dank bin ich ja Informatiker und zum Glück, da bin ich auch sehr, sehr froh drüber, gibt es ja keine Zost-Fair-Patenten. Wo ich auch, ja, wo ich selber sehr glücklich bin. Aber ich bin ja selber halt Autor auch von Veröffentlichungen und muss jetzt also zumindest mal sagen, die Veröffentlichungen, die so im Bereich Informatik stattfinden, die sind eigentlich fast alle zugänglich. Also meine sind zum Beispiel auch auf meiner Homepage drauf. Und eigentlich schicken die Autoren sowas auch immer zu, wenn man sich natürlich auch immer liest, wenn einer das Zeug halt liest. Prinzipiell finde ich eigentlich die Herangehensweise ganz richtig. Und eigentlich gibt es einen Kreditpunkt, den ich eigentlich auch relativ stichfest finde. Also was zum Beispiel gegen diese allgemeine Veröffentlichung im Internet spricht, da hat mich nämlich mal einer dann drauf angesprochen und der hat gesagt, das Problem ist, dass dieser Deal zwischen Europa, USA und Japan und Australien relativ gut funktioniert. Aber er sagt, ein relativ großes Problem ist, dass zum Beispiel gerade China sehr, sehr viele wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen dann daraus abruft. Aber selber seine eigenen Forschungsergebnisse nur sehr, sehr spärlich wiederum der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung stellt. Also dass die sich diesen Deal dann in gewisser Weise entziehen.
Das ist ein Gerücht, das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht?
Nee. Also das mag vielleicht in manchen Bereichen zu sein, aber die, die ich kenne, ist nicht so. Im Gegenteil. Also gerade bei der Kryptographie ist es so, dass einige der wichtigsten Ergebnisse in den letzten Jahren von chinesischen Forschern kommen. Und im Übrigen selbst, wenn es so wäre, entweder es geht uns um die Forschung oder es geht uns nicht um die Forschung. Und wenn es um die Forschung geht, dann veröffentlichen wir die Sachen. Das ist für uns gut und wenn es für andere gut ist, naja. Na und?
Naja, außerdem muss man auch mit einem guten Beispiel vorangehen. Du kannst ja nicht nur, weil es ein schlechtes Beispiel in der Welt gibt, dann alle anderen zurückhalten. Also von daher.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die sich von selbst reguliert. Wenn du was erfindest und du machst ein Paper zu und die Chinesen klauen das und machen auch was damit, dann bist du immer noch vorne auf deinem Fachbereich. Das heißt, du hast den Wegweiser gesteckt, wo es lang geht. Und du bist der, der vorne ist in der Forschung. Du hast immer noch einen Vorteil, selbst wenn sie es geklaut haben.
Wenn ich die Sachen veröffentliche, also ich bin ja derzeit nicht einer kommerziellen Umsetzung interessiert. Wenn ich es veröffentliche, freue ich mich ja gerade, wenn Leute darauf aufbauen. Dafür mache ich auch gerade die Forschung. Das war, wie gesagt, ein Kritikpunkt, der da mal angebracht wurde. Wo ich mal wissen wollte, wie da eigentlich der weitere Stand ist, weil darüber habe ich bisher nur mit einer einzigen Person geredet. Deswegen fand ich den mal ganz stichhaltig.
Es gibt noch einen Punkt, also das mit der auf der eigenen Homepage veröffentlichen, ist ein guter erster Anfang, aber ich war auch mal an der Uni, meine Homepage ist inzwischen weg. Und so wird dir das auch gehen. Wenn du die Uni verlässt, irgendwann ist deine Homepage weg und dann hast du vielleicht ein Backup von deinem Paper oder vielleicht auch nicht. Also wir sagen, nicht nur das soll allgemeinfrei sein, sondern der Staat soll es ins Internet stellen und soll dafür sorgen, dass es verfügbar bleibt.
Ja, dass das nicht eigentlich schon gewährleistet. Na gut, im Internet nicht, eigentlich ist es durch die Bibliothek.
Genau, Bibliotheken sind schön und gut, aber im Moment ist es so, dass du mit Steuergeldern finanziert, dein Paper forschst, und dann gibst du das einem Verlag und der publiziert das und dann kaufen alle anderen Unis das von dem Verlag. Und die Leistung ist aber von dir gekommen, und die habe ich schon bezahlt als Steuerzahler. Und ich zahle jetzt also zweimal dafür. Erstens einmal an dich, damit du das forschst, was gut ist, und einmal an die Verlage, und das pro Uni. Und das kostet einen Schweine Geld.
Also dem Problem bin ich ja vollkommen bewusst. Das ist ja wie gesagt, und deswegen stelle ich das auch öffentlich online, beziehungsweise gebe ich auch, also ich kann auch davon reden, es ist eigentlich gang und gäbe auch Paper so weiter auszuteilen, wenn man die als PDFs hat und so. Ein sehr großer Teil sind ja auch schon zugänglich durch die digitalen Bibliotheken von der ACM und von der AIWI, aber da zahlen die hochschon, so wie ich weiß, auch sehr, sehr viel Geld für, um diese Zugänge zu haben. Also die sind auch nicht gerade billig.
Das ist nicht billig, genau.
Was mich jetzt auch noch interessieren würde, ist, es gibt jetzt auch so Forschung, die wird dann teilweise aus der Industrie finanziert. Was soll denn damit geschehen? Also Drittmittel-Forschung heißt das dann, glaube ich.
Ja, da hatte ich auch mal eine Diskussion gehabt. Da hatten wir mal einen Ringverlesungskurs, nämlich über Patente gehabt. Wie gesagt, zum Glück sind wir in der Informatik da nicht ganz so stark von betroffen. Aber da habe ich den Dozenten mal genau die gleiche Frage gestellt. Da habe ich den aber auch mal genau, exakt nämlich diese Frage gestellt. Da habe ich gesagt, also im Endeffekt, ich zahle ja dann für dieses Forschungsprojekt, ich zahle für den Anteil der Hochschule, die das macht. Warum soll dann das, was da rauskommt, dieses Patent halt nicht allgemein zur Verfügung stehen für alle anderen? Weil alle haben ja schon dafür gezahlt. Da ist dann der Dozent, der von einem großen internationalen Maschinenbauer kommt, nicht wirklich darauf eingelangen. Also ich habe da eigentlich genau die gleiche Meinung. Also wenn man da sagt, da wurde halt dann irgendwas erforscht und da halt Steuermittel drin sind, dann hat man es ja schon bereits bezahlt.
Also eine Sache kann man drüber nachdenken. Also man könnte ja sagen, Patente sind nicht generell schlecht, aber unser Land patentiert es, damit quasi andere Länder Lizenzgebühren zahlen müssen, wenn sie unsere Forschung gebrauchen. Also da könnte man von mir aus drüber reden. Aber ich als Steuerzahler in dem Land, der das finanziert habe, sehe nicht einen, nochmal Lizenzgebühren zahlen zu müssen.
Obwohl wir dann wieder bei der gleichen Frage eigentlich fast wären wie bei der Forschung. Also warum sollte dann mit einer Forschung eine Abschottung der einzelnen Länder möglich sein, bei den Patenten eine Abschottung der einzelnen Länder möglich sein, aber nicht bei der Forschung?
Na, weil einen langen Weg geht man immer in einzelnen Schritten. Und wir können jetzt hier nicht alles auf einmal umwerfen. Aber langfristig bin ich persönlich auch der Meinung, dass wir Patente ganz abschaffen sollten.
Also im Endeffekt bin ich auch gegen Patente, weil das greift zwar ein bisschen weit, aber ich glaube zum Beispiel, das geht zwar auch von der Netzpolitik weg, aber eine Menge Bereiche, wo es Probleme gibt, zum Beispiel insbesondere der Gesundheitsbereich, da sind Pharma-Patente glaube ich ein Teil des Problems, dass Medikamentenpreise dann auch so hoch sind. Da muss man natürlich gucken, wie man das anders schützen könnte. Ja, das ist ein Teil des Problems, würde ich sagen. Teil. Nicht das komplette Problem.
Dann machen wir mal eine eigene Sendung zu.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also mit den Patenten kommen wir dann auch nicht weit. Das ist ganz schön krass, so ein paar Thesen hier aufzustellen. Dann schaffen wir es weiter. Weil, Stefan, letzte Frage ist zu sagen, ich glaube, dass diese ganze Diskussion um die Patenten also tatsächlich realpolitisch spannend ist, weil ich glaube, dass viel bei der Uni ja mittlerweile auch finanziert wird über Drittmittel quasi und wenn man sagt, es gibt gar keine Patente mehr, zumindest in unserem Land nicht, dann gehen die halt woanders hin oder das Geld bricht weg und da müsste man echt nochmal sagen, also wahrscheinlich den ganzen Bildungsapparat dann irgendwie einmal umbauen.
Das stimmt halt gerade nicht.
Das glaube ich aber zum sehr, sehr großen Teil nicht. Also wie gesagt, gerade ich so als Informatiker und im Softwarebereich, da gibt es nun in Europa keine Patente. Also wurde alles über das Urheberrecht gemacht und die Wirtschaft funktioniert da eigentlich auch sehr, sehr gut und insbesondere gibt es da einem auch, wenn man jetzt sich selbstständig macht mit einer Idee, einen sehr, sehr großen Druck, dass man sich auf nicht einen bestimmten technischen Stand ausruhen kann, weil halt solange ich 25 Jahre mehr Patentgebühren bezahle, wächst da eh keiner mehr nach, sondern man ist halt dann ständig auch getrieben von dem Punkt, wo man halt gerade ist, auch noch weiter zu machen und halt irgendwie den Kunden noch weiter zu überzeugen oder die Abnehmer der eigenen Software. Also ich würde sagen, Patente, also...
Machen wir mal eine eigene Sendung für. Das ist ein größeres Thema.
Stefan, aber vielen Dank auf jeden Fall. Bis dahin, tschüss. So, ihr könnt weiterhin anrufen, 0331 70 97 110 und wir sind jetzt bei den Patenten angekommen. Was kommt als nächstes?
Ja, wir haben noch 19. Nein, also die nächste These geht um private Daten und da geht es darum, dass man dem Staat eine Datensparsamkeitsregelung auferlegt und natürlich auch den Firmen. Ja, für die Firmen haben wir dann ein Konzept namens Datenbrief, das haben wir schon an anderer Stelle erklärt, wie das funktionieren soll. Aber wir möchten gerne dafür sorgen, dass sowohl der Staat als auch Firmen keinen Grund haben, Daten über mich zu sammeln, die sie nicht brauchen und wenn sie sie haben, möchten wir aktiv Anreiz schaffen, dass die Daten nicht gespeichert werden.
Definiere Daten, die sie nicht brauchen. Also, wie unterscheiden die sich von Daten, die sie brauchen?
Na, also ein Beispiel dafür wäre, dass wir einen Personalausweis haben. Das sind jetzt nicht nur Daten, aber so als anschauliches Beispiel. Wir haben einen Personalausweis, die Briten haben keinen, wusstest du das?
Äh, ja, das ist das...
Die Amerikaner haben auch keinen.
Ich hab damals dort gemerkt, dass da sehr viel Aufregung war, als sie einen einführen wollten.
Genau, die wollen seit 30 Jahren einen einführen und sie brauchen ihn einfach bis heute nicht.
Und das Schöne ist ja, als Deutscher denkt man so, der Personalausweis gab es schon immer, wird schon irgendwie seine Berechtigung haben. Warum brauchen wir denn keinen Personalausweis?
Weißt du eigentlich, warum wir keinen Fingerabdruck im Personalausweis haben? Wir hatten mal einen bei den Nazis und die Alliäten haben das abgeschafft, weil sie gesagt haben, das ist unwürdig.
Oh, und jetzt haben wir wieder einen, toll, ne?
Aber trotzdem, warum braucht es keinen Personalausweis?
Weil du kannst auch ohne ihn überleben und es ist nicht so, dass die da weniger Strafverfolgung hätten oder mehr Kriminalität. Oder dass da die Banken weniger Schrottanleihen kaufen. Ich meine, die ganzen Probleme, mit denen wir tatsächlich zu kämpfen haben, die haben alle wenig damit zu tun, ob ich einen Personalausweis habe oder nicht.
Aber andererseits sozusagen ist, macht der Personalausweis auch viele Dinge einfacher. Also wenn ich irgendwo nachweisen will, ich bin es, kann ich einfach vorzeigen, das glaubt mir auch jeder. Wie soll das denn dann, wenn es keinen Personalausweis gibt, geklärt werden? Okay, da verstehe ich jetzt aber den Unterschied nicht. Also warum sozusagen...
Ja warum haben wir denn einen Personalausweis und einen Pass?
Ist doch blöd, oder?
Weil der Personalausweis so klein praktisch zum Rumtragen ist und beim Pass kann man reinstempeln.
Und die Gesundheitskarte, wie ist der mit der Gesundheitskarte? Nee, warum haben wir denn Gesundheitskarten? Ich meine, es gibt so viele Beispiele, die vielleicht alle nicht offensichtlich sind. Oder die Mautdaten. Warum müssen wir denn Mautdaten aufheben von LKWs, die irgendwo lang fahren? Brauchen wir das?
Nee.
Die fallen am Bahn...
Verkehrsflusskontrolle.
Ja, Bullshit, wenn ich das mal sagen darf. Nein, wir sammeln an allen Orten und älten irgendwelche Daten, die wir nicht wirklich brauchen, weil es nämlich einfacher ist, Daten zu sammeln, als vorher darüber nachzudenken, ob man sie eigentlich braucht oder nicht.
Und das soll in Zukunft dann geschehen?
In Zukunft soll es ein richtiges Gebot der Datensparsamkeit geben, dass der Staat begründen muss, und zwar nicht nur Larifari, ja, das ist besser für die Strafverfolgung, sondern tatsächlich handfest begründen, und zwar mit vorliegenden Zahlen und Untersuchungen, dass dieses Datum tatsächlich nützlich ist und hilft. Und dann muss immer noch abgewogen werden, ob der Schaden, der entsteht, dadurch dass es gesammelt wird, den Nutzen nicht übersteigt. Und erst dann darf das Datum gesammelt werden. Wir möchten gerne eine Bürokratie schaffen, an der Stelle, die ist aufwendig und widerlich und eklig macht, mehr Daten zu speichern, als du brauchst.
Es ist derzeit ein Problem, dass es billiger ist, die Daten einfach zu sammeln, als Überlegungen anzustellen, wozu brauche ich die eigentlich.
Das ist auch eins der Hauptprobleme. Du hörst doch immer, dass die Leute Probleme haben, Datenbanken zusammenzuführen. Überleg doch mal, was heißt denn das? Die Leute haben Datenbanken, die sie nicht zusammengeführt haben. Das heißt, sie wollen jetzt Verbindungen schaffen, an die sie nicht gedacht haben, als sie die Daten gesammelt haben. Das heißt, sie haben die Daten gesammelt, bevor sie wussten, dass sie sie dafür brauchen. Vielleicht brauchen sie sie für was anderes. In manchen Fällen mag das stimmen. In vielen Fällen heißt es aber einfach, wir haben die Daten, dann sammeln wir sie halt.
Und so läuft das. André findet das auch nicht toll, er hat hier angerufen.
Hallo André, dann erzähl mal.
Hallo Fritz Team, hallo Fefe, hallo Gast, den ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr so in Erinnerung habe. Es geht mir ganz vor allem darum, wenn der Staat schon so viel Daten hat, und der hat ja ganz verdammt viele Daten über mich, warum muss ich dann jedes Mal, wenn ich irgendwas beantrage, ganz viel in irgendwelche Papierbögen einfüllen? Und selbst wenn ich das online mache, muss ich ganz viel selber ausfüllen. Und es geht ja noch weiter. Warum muss ich, wenn ich sowas beantrage, dann noch meinen Eltern, zum Beispiel beim Unterhalt, was in die Hand geben, was die denn wiederum deren Chef in die Hand geben, was der dann ausfüllen muss? Warum kann ich wenigstens einen Nutzen draus gezogen werden? Also das ist so eine Sache, die ich mir einfach nicht kommt.
Aber, aber, das ist gut so. Das ist eine These, die ich seit einigen Jahren äußere. Unser bester Schutz vor dem Unterdrückungsstaat ist die Inkompetenz der Unterdrücker.
Kann man öfter mal auf deinem Blog lesen, ja. Aber ich möchte trotzdem irgendwo an der Stelle, ich meine, Sie haben doch so viele Verbindungen. Es muss doch aber möglich sein, dann für uns einen Nutzen rauszuziehen. Also, das, das, das will mir nicht in den Kopf. Das kann mir auch nicht einfach so abtun, weil Sie doof sind. Es, es, ich finde, es sollte auch eine These sein, dass ja eben, dass aus diesen ganzen Geschichten, die der Staat ohnehin erhoben hat, ein Nutzen für den Bürger gezogen werden muss. Und zwar ein fühlbarer. Ich meine, man kann ja mit dem dem ja sehres Bullshit-Bingo weitermachen und kann sagen, macht doch mal irgendwelche, irgendwelche Thesen, die sagen, es muss ein fühlbarer Nutzen für den Bürger dabei herauskommen.
Das passiert aber nicht. Also ich meine, wir versuchen jetzt mal so eine These zu formulieren.
Ich möchte kurz eine Zwischenfrage stellen. Und zwar ist es, plädierst du dafür, das was Fefe gerade gesagt hat, also Daten dürfen nur dann gesammelt werden, wenn sie einen praktischen Nutzen haben? Oder plädierst du dafür, die sollen ruhig Daten sammeln, aber dann sollen sie wenigstens was ordentliches draus bauen?
Nein, ich bin eigentlich sogar für beides. Ich meine, der Staat braucht ja die Daten.
Das geht nicht. Weil es sich ausschließt. Entweder sagst du so sparsam wie möglich.
Wir haben sogar noch eine These in die Gegenrichtung.
Ja, aber der Staat braucht doch einige Daten bei mich. Der Staat muss doch meinetwegen wissen, ja, keine Ahnung, ich bin so und so alt, meine Eltern sind die und die. Das muss er wissen.
Du bist dafür, dass alle diese Daten zusammengeführt werden, was ja eigentlich gerade nicht passieren soll, wie wir heute hier schon gehört haben, weil es praktischer ist.
Ich bin dafür, dass, wenn die schon zusammengeführt werden und der Staat uns das irgendwie einrichtet...
Nee, das passiert ja gerade nicht. Das ist ja dein Kritikpunkt, dass es nicht passiert.
Dann sollen sie es vielleicht auch zu unserem Guten tun.
Ja, guck mal, das Problem ist, wenn du so eine Regelung hast, dann hast du nämlich die Schranke dafür, Daten zu heben auf es ist nützlich gelegt. Und dann werden sie alles speichern. Ja, ich sag mal ein Beispiel. Ich fände es persönlich sehr nützlich, wenn ich keine Steuererklärung abgeben müsste, denn alle Zahlungen, die ich so mache, gehen über irgendwelche Karten oder Konten. Und da hat der Staat E-Interfaces, um einsehen zu können. Und eigentlich kann der Staat auch meine Steuererklärung für mich machen. Ja, das könnte man argumentieren. Das würde mir echt Stress sparen. Aber wollen wir das? Nein, wollen wir nicht.
Ja, könnte du noch dein Auto überwachen, weil dann hast du gleich ein Fahrtbuch.
Genau, wir können auch Maut, genau. Wir machen einfach Maut, indem wir GPS einbauen in alle Autos. Eine tolle Idee, haben die Niederländer auch gemacht. Wollen wir aber nicht.
Es gibt ja auch trotzdem viel banalere Beispiele, wo es sinnvoll wäre. Ich habe Bekannte, die wollten heiraten. Du kannst dir gar nicht vorstellen, was das für ein Stress ist, zwischen den Behörden, bis du alle Papiere zusammen hast, damit die Leute heiraten können. Obwohl, vom Prinzip, das alles Behörden sind, die eigentlich miteinander zu tun haben. Von der Meldebehörde und dem Standesamt usw. Das liegt ja jetzt nicht so weit auseinander.
Du musst an die Arbeitsplätze denken, wie das schafft.
Das ist vielleicht das, was man sich fragen würde. Was machst du mit der vielen Zeit, die du auf einmal gewinnst? Und was machst du mit den vielen Beamten, die auf einmal überflüssig werden? Und mit dem ganzen Apparat. Und das ist ja vom Prinzip das, was wir bei jeder Behörde immer wieder sehen, ist, dass jede Behörde nur versucht, eigentlich ihre Prozesse möglichst so komplex zu halten, damit eben keine Macht abgebaut wird, keine Arbeitsplätze abgebaut werden.
Aber ich verstehe, ist das doch eine gute Idee, weil dann jeder genau nur die Daten verarbeitet, die er selber braucht, und es gibt keine Zentralisierung.
Genau, das wollen wir auch so. Das ist übrigens derselbe Gedanke, der unserem Staat zugrunde legt, wenn wir mal drüber nachdenken. Wir haben einen föderalen Staat, und wir haben diverse Checks und Balances, die darauf ausgelegt sind, dass kein einzelner Triebtäter loslaufen kann. Wenn wir einen noch so verrückten Kanzler haben, der kann nicht einfach irgendwelche Gesetze machen, sondern da muss noch der Bundesrat zustimmen, und der Bundespräsident muss es unterschreiben, und das Verfassungsgericht muss der Meinung sein, das ist verfassungsgerecht. Diese Art von Verteilung ist die Grundidee von eigentlich allen machthabenden demokratischen Strukturen, und das sollen wir auch für Daten haben.
Ich fasse mal zusammen, André hätte es gerne ein bisschen bequemer als dafür auch sozusagen bereit, das ein bisschen aufzugeben mit den Datensammeln, aber ihr sagt, nee, nur so wenig Daten wie möglich, und vorher soll gewusst werden, dafür nehmen wir auch in Kauf, dass es sozusagen genauso unbequem ist wie jetzt, bzw. vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen aufwendiger wird. Weil wir gerade, also irgendwie die Zeit läuft uns jetzt schon davon, und wir sind noch nicht mal bei These 6 oder so, weil wir aber gerade über den Personalausweis gesprochen haben, würde ich gerne den Patrick nochmal dazuholen, der Erfahrungen damit hat, steht hier. Patrick, hallo. Was willst du uns über den Personalausweis erzählen?
Ja, also ich bin einfach nur, also ich hab mir einen Bart wachsen lassen.
Ein was? Ein Bart?
Einen Bart wachsen lassen, ja.
Ein Bart?
Ja, ich hatte vorher keine Gesichtbehauung und dann bin ich mit Gesichtbehauung über die Grenze gefahren. Nach Tschengen.
Das macht man auch nicht.
So, dann hab ich Gesichtbehauung gehabt und dann waren die deutschen Fälle und haben gesagt, das sind sie ja nicht. Im Personal ausweist. So, ich so, ja klar bin ich das. Und dann meinte der tschechische Grenzbeamte, der konnte dann halt auch tschechisch und der hat dann gemeint, ja, da müssen sie jetzt rasieren. Und hat das aber erschärft.
Wir haben mal so einen Scherz intern gehabt im CCC. Wir haben gesagt, wir lassen uns einen Biometrie-Bard wachsen.
Ja, genau.
Also du hast jetzt einen Biometrie-Bard.
Also ich hatte einen Bart, ja, und damit hätten die mich, die deutschen Kölner eigentlich, niemals über die Grenze laufen lassen. So, und die zweite Sache ist halt die. Mein Bruder, der hat halt diesen Bio-Pastbeamten tragen müssen, weil er nach Amerika gefahren ist. Und die waren halt mit dem Biometriebild nicht zufrieden. Und dann haben die das halt so lange gedreht. Also erstmal ist er halt zum Fotografen hin. Er hat gesagt, ja, das Bild ist nicht okay. Dann haben die noch ein Bild gemacht und dann war es dem Fotografen egal.
Das wurde dann gefotoshoppt, ja, das bei unseren Pässen genau so.
Genau, dann wurde das gefotoshoppt. Und dann war das okay und dann ist das Fotografen-Bild in den Pass.
Es gibt Leute, die sind einfach nicht kompatibel.
Das ist doch dann wieder ein super Argument für Fingerabdrücke, Wien-Muster, Wien-Erkennung.
Das ist ein Argument dafür, dass du dieses Bild nicht brauchst. Denn wenn du es bräuchtest, wärst du an der Stelle mit Photoshop nicht weitergekommen. Hier greift also unsere These private Daten schützen. Das sind Daten, die sie nicht brauchen. Datensparsamkeit sagt, dürfen sie nicht erheben. Fertig. Genau das meinen wir damit. Genau. Wir sind uns alle einig. Was für eine langweilige Sendung. Nimm noch mal ein paar Querulanten rein hier.
Alles klar, gut.
Danke Patrick.
Das wird eine super Geschichte. Die wird bestimmt in die Annalen eingehen. Und, ähm, ja, Querulanten? Also du meinst Leute, die nicht deiner Meinung sind?
Äh, na, so weit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen.
Na gut, wenn ihr euch jetzt auf irgendeine Art und Weise angesprochen fühlt, gilt folgendes.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
Leute, jetzt kommen die Thesen.
Wenn das verdammte rote Licht an ist, ist das Mikrofon offen.
Ja, na und?
Ist das jetzt geheim gewesen oder was? Weiß ich ja nicht.
Aber ihr tut immer so. Nein, nein, nein. Wir sind eine anonyme Aussage. Hör mal, das ist doch hier Teil unseres Jobs, oder? So ein bisschen Mysterie aufzubauen. Ah, verstehe.
Okay, jetzt ist der Jochen da. Jochen fährt das unreglementierte Internet.
Bist du ein Querulant, Jochen?
Guten Morgen. Ja, Querulant, ja. Wenn es nach der Gesetzgebung geht, dann bin ich ja wohl schon noch irgendwo ein Querulant. Denn Netzneutralität finde ich doch schon irgendwie ein wichtiges Argument. Ja, geht doch nicht an, dass man zum Beispiel... Zum Beispiel Google, das habe ich gerade eben schon der Redaktion gesagt. Man findet doch auf Google gar keinen Youporn mehr. Wie kommt denn das? Das ist doch auch eine Art von Reglementierung. Ja, jetzt nur mal ein blödes Beispiel.
Das ist der Jugendschutz. Das ist noch ein ganz anderes Ding. Das ist in der Tat eine These, die wir noch nicht erwähnt haben.
Ja gut, Jugendschutz hin oder her. Das mit den Netzsperren, von wegen Mrs. von der Leyen und ihre Zensosler-Sachen und all hin und her. Nur dadurch, dass ich das verschwinden lasse, durch welche Methode jetzt auch immer, durch Proxy-Server oder dass ich ein DNS-Sperre dahinter herhauere oder was auch immer, dadurch verschwinden die Sachen doch nicht aus der Welt.
Du, das ist eine Einstellung bei Google. Das kannst du auch einschalten und dann kriegst du auch wieder Porn.
Na gut, das wusste ich nicht.
Wenn es um Porn geht, helfen wir gerne.
Na ja, sehr schön. Ich finde es gut, dass wir mir auch helfen konnten. Chaosradio, die Service-Sendung. Viel Spaß dabei. Und wir haben jetzt noch den Thomas, der etwas noch zum Thema Software zu sagen hat.
Ich möchte eigentlich direkt zum Punkt kommen.
Eine gute Idee. Passiert viel zu selten. Vor allem Politiker machen das selten.
Könnt ihr vom CCC nicht mal eine Software entwickeln, mit der man Informationen zu politischen Problemen irgendwie sammeln kann?
Ich glaube, es gibt die Software, die heißt Wiki.
Ja, es gibt erstens Wikipedia. Da stehen auch ganz viele echt unangenehme Details zu Politikern. Und wenn sie da noch nicht stehen, dann tragt ihr sie ein. Und dann gibt es Abgeordnetenwatch. Da stehen auch ganz viele echt peinliche Sachen. Das Hauptproblem ist nicht die Software. Die Software gibt es. Du kannst über Wikipedia alles eintragen, wenn du möchtest. Oder kannst du auch ein eigenes Wiki machen.
Du kannst die Information zwar sammeln, aber du kannst sie schlecht darstellen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn du ein Softwareprojekt hast und das Ding hat Probleme, also Bugs oder so was, dann trägst du das ja nicht in einem Wiki ein, sondern in einem Bug Tracker.
Also du willst Bugs von Politikern sammeln?
Nicht von Politikern, sondern vom politischen System.
Und von Gesetzen, von Gesetzentwürfen. Das wäre doch mal geil. Ein Bug Tracker für Gesetzentwürfe, wollen wir das nicht mal machen? Das ist ein cooler Punkt, den notieren wir mal.
Aber sag doch mal kurz für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was ein Bug Tracker ist.
Es ist ein Software-System, wo man konkrete Informationen über Probleme in Systemen an zentraler Stelle sammeln kann.
Und das zeigt dann automatisiert auch an, dass hier Komponente blabla hat Probleme mit Komponente blabla.
Ja genau, und man kann die auch halt filtern nach Priorität und so weiter. Und man kann halt Analyse an zentraler Stelle sammeln.
Das könnte man dann gleich noch in Walomaten draufsetzen.
Ich weiß nicht, aber...
Nee, eigentlich kannst du Gesetze automatisiert durchfallen lassen, wenn sie mehr als einen Bugs haben.
Also jetzt mal ernsthaft, also ihr vom CCC habt ja eine Menge politische Probleme auf dem Radar. Aber es gibt ja noch eine ganze Menge andere politische Probleme, zum Beispiel Atomkraft oder Bürgerrechte, Frauenrechte und so weiter. Ich meine, die Informationen dazu sind über Tausende von Webseiten und Blogs verstreut. Und wenn man die wirklich mal versucht zu sammeln, dann wird man wahnsinnig, weil das so verstreut ist. Das ist unglaublich eigentlich. Und es wäre eigentlich mal schön, wenn man das an einer Zentralstelle so sammeln könnte.
Vom Prinzip geht das ja Richtung Open Government so, dass du eben die Bürger mit einbeziehen kannst in Entscheidungsprozesse, den Bürgern ermöglicht Feedback zu geben zu bestimmten Dingen. Also die Software dafür existiert in vielen Fällen natürlich noch nicht, aber das ist so, ich sag mal, die Bewegung, die in diese Richtung geht und die eben ermöglichen möchte, dass viel mehr Leute sich an diesen ganzen Prozessen beteiligen. Und das ist natürlich sicherlich sinnvoll.
Von Open Governance möchte ich gar nicht nochmal reden. Es geht eigentlich erstmal nur darum, Informationen überhaupt zu sammeln. Was man damit macht, das ist schon der zweite Schritt.
Du willst eine praktische Lösung, aber der Redakteur hat dich eingetragen, du seist in der Softwarebranche tätig. Warum schreibst du diese Software nicht?
Der hat einen nicht überhört. Sonst würde ich das gerne machen, aber mir fehlt das Geld dazu.
Das Geld, ok. Nein, der ist gilt. Dann gehst du zum CCC und lässt dir das zeigen. Wir haben schöne Hacker-Bases und da hängen Programmierer ab. Dann kann man hingehen und sich das zeigen lassen. Also unabhängig davon, verteilt von Daten wird gern als Nachteil gesehen, aber es ist auch ein Vorteil, weil es nämlich das System weniger angreifbar macht. Wenn du eine zentrale Webseite hast, wo alle Daten sind, dann müssen diese Webseite runterfahren und dann ist deine ganze Bewegung entkernt. Aber wenn die Daten dezentral liegen, dann ist das schwieriger. Deswegen ist auch der CCC eine dezentrale Vereinigung.
Aber schick ist die Idee schon.
Schick ist die Idee schon und ich finde auch, man sollte das tun. Software zum Sammeln und Verteilen von Daten, das ist im Grunde die Haupt- und Kernaufgabe von Informatik und überhaupt von Software.
Thomas hat die Idee gehabt, vielen Dank dafür.
Wie viele Thesen haben wir jetzt noch übrig eigentlich? Na, wir werden sie ja nicht alle verlesen.
Aber wie viele Thesen haben wir noch?
Noch zwei in dem Blog, den wir angefangen haben.
Die skippen wir?
Nee, Moment, ganz kurz sprechen wir die an.
Okay, wir machen jetzt Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Gut, danach sprechen wir die an und danach machen wir weiter. Alles klar.
Habt ihr euch auch immer schon mal gefragt, wo mir ihr erstes Video gedreht haben?
Was Apparat und Modeselektor am hackischen Markt treiben?
Oder warum sich Wir-sind-Helden-partout-nicht-auf-ein-Band-Namen einigen konnten? Die Fritz Music Tours.
Auf den Spuren der Berliner Popmusik.
Jetzt auch mit Walking Tour.
Zu Fuß durch Berlins musikalische Mitte.
Immer mittwochs und sonntags.
Und die Bustour gibt's natürlich auch weiterhin.
Immer samstags oder nach Wunschtermin.
Wann genau und wo genau?
FritzD.
Fritz Music Tours Berlin.
Neue Musikgeschichten zu neuer Musikgeschichte.
Zu Fuß, im Bus und an der Rufschrauber-Variante arbeiten wir noch.
Und das hört man. Um kurz nach halb 12. Mit Kaiathan Dürlich.
Deutschland hat einen neuen Bundespräsidenten. Die Bundesversammlung wählte nach über neun Stunden Christian Wulf. Der Kandidat von Union und FDP erreicht im dritten Wahlgang eine Mehrheit von 625 Stimmen. Der Bewerber von SPD und Grünen Gauck bekam etwa 130 Stimmen weniger. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel begrüßte die Wahl von Wulf und erklärte, dass er der richtige Mann für dieses Amt sei. Wulf wird dann morgen in seinem neuen Amt vereidigt. Die EU, bzw. am Freitag vereidigt, Entschuldigung. Die EU will, dass die einzelnen Mitgliedsländer freiwillig ihre Ferienzeiten untereinander abstimmen. Damit will sie verhindern, dass alle Leute zur gleichen Zeit in den Urlaub fahren. Das wiederum wäre gut für den Tourismus. Die Branche beschwert sich außerhalb der Hochsaison über leere Betten. Deutschland reagierte auf den Vorschlag skeptisch. Die einzelnen Bundesländer hätten schließlich jetzt schon zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten Ferien. Hurricane Alex behindert die Ölbekämpfung im Golf von Mexiko. Wegen meterhoher Wellen mussten die Rettungsschiffe den Hafen anlaufen. Das Abschöpfen und Abfackeln des Ölteppichs kam zum Stillstand. Die US-Regierung hat sich mittlerweile entschlossen, ausländische Hilfsangebote für die Ölbekämpfung anzunehmen. Es handelt sich um 22 Angebote aus 12 Ländern. Deutschland ist bereit, unter anderem Barrieren zum Ölaufsaugen und technisches Personal zur Verfügung zu stellen. Start! Beim Tennis-Grosslamp-Turnier in Wimbledon ist Titelverteidiger Roger Federer im Viertelfinale überraschend ausgeschieden. Der sechsmalige Wimbledon-Sieger unterlag dem Tschechen Tomas Berdig in vier Sätzen und erreichte damit erstmals seit 2002 nicht in der Runde die letzten acht. Wittenberge und Angermünde 17 Grad haben wir jetzt die aktuellen Temperaturen Frankfurt, Neuropie 19, Potsdam und Cottbus 21 und Berlin zwischen 18 und 22 Grad. Heute Nacht sind hier und da noch ein paar Wolgen unterwegs, aber es bleibt meistens trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen heute bis auf 11 Grad runter. Morgen wird es wieder ziemlich schön, viel Sonne und wieder sehr, sehr heiß draußen mit bis zu 30 Grad. Vorsicht auf der AC nördlicher Berliner Ringrichtung 3K-Felan. Zwischen Weißensee und dem Reich Pankow steht im Baustellenbereich ein kaputtes Auto. In der Gegenrichtung ist zwischen Kreuz Oranienburg und Birkenwerder die linke Spur dicht. A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt Oder zwischen Mürose und Frankfurt Oder. West, da gibt es Gefahr durch ein unbeleuchtetes Fahrzeug. Auf der rechten Spur da wird er also ganz besonders vorsichtig fahren. A20 Kreuz Uckermark Richtung Rostock zwischen Bremslauer Ost und Pasewalk Süd. Wir sind in beiden Richtungen Tiere auf der Fahrbahn unterwegs. Und das besonders in der Höhe Parkplatz Klokko Ost. Und das war's. Und wie sagt man das jetzt richtig? Ich kann das. Wenn man das dann liest... Grenzlem. Grenzlem ist das peinlich. Gott, ist das peinlich. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Trignitz.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaosradio in Blue Moon und es geht heute um Thesen zur Netzpolitik, weil der Herr de Maizière ja in der letzten Woche 14 davon an den Start gebracht haben. Fefe vom Chaos Computer Club und Daniel meinen, das ist irgendwie nicht so golden und von den 14 kann man genau keine verwenden.
Wir müssen mindestens 15 machen, ist doch völlig klar. Mindestens.
Und deswegen haben sie selber welche mitgebracht. Wir hatten schon, dass Daten geschützt werden sollen, dass öffentliche Daten an den Start kommen sollen, dass jeder User einen Internetanschluss haben soll. Wir haben jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Es gibt eigentlich mehr Thesen, als ich vermute, wie wir umbringen. Kurz zu dem Blog, wo wir jetzt gerade sind.
Unterbringen.
Mit den öffentlichen Daten.
Also, vom Prinzip, wenn wir schon dabei sind, alle möglichen Dinge zu schützen, dann muss auch, und das ist sicherlich ein ganz wichtiger Bestandteil, müssen Publikationen im Internet auch geschützt werden können. Sodass eben so etwas wie Zensur oder auch das Ansicht bringen von unbequemen Wahrheiten über unser Kommunikationsmedium Nummer eins, dass das eben auch geschützt wird. Und das ist etwas, was in Deutschland zum Beispiel auch fehlt. Also es gibt keinen Schutz für sogenannte Whistleblower hier, der im Gesetz verankert wäre. Es gibt zwar umgekehrt den Schutz für Journalisten und die Möglichkeit, dass Journalisten ihre Quellen schützen können und dann eben dazu was publizieren. Aber es gibt keinen Schutz gesetzlich verankert für die Menschen, die eben etwas ans Licht bringen können. Das knüpft ja auch ein bisschen an das, was der Anrufer eben, ich habe den Namen vergessen, gesagt hatte, nämlich dass wir die Möglichkeit haben müssen, Bugs in der Gesellschaft zu tracken oder gewisse Missstände aufzudecken. Das ist was, was wir uns sicherlich auch wünschen würden für die netzpolitische Seite hier.
Das heißt, es geht jetzt aber darum, dass die Leute geschützt werden, die diese Informationen ins Netz bringen, nicht die Informationen im Netz selber.
Also stell dir vor, du bist oberst klein und du hast gerade...
Nein, das ist nicht klar. Es hört sich nur am Anfang so an, als ob sozusagen jede Information, die einmal im Netz gelandet ist, dann auch dort bleiben darf.
Das hängt natürlich auch zusammen.
Hängt schon so miteinander.
Ja, das hängt aber auch relativ eng miteinander zusammen. Also es bringt dir auch nichts, wenn du nur den Menschen schützen kannst, aber niemand kann das im Internet publizieren, weil die Publikation irgendwie zensiert wird. Das sind zwei Punkte, die relativ eng miteinander verknüpft sind.
Also finde ich auch noch ein Problemfeld, dass man dann sagen kann, ja gut, aber ich möchte vielleicht Daten, die über mich ins Netz kommen, dann doch wieder löschen. Dann ist die Frage wohl, verläuft die Grenze. Aber das führt zu weit. Wir haben noch ganz viele andere Thesen.
Relativ eng damit zusammenhängt natürlich, und das ist eigentlich ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, das Recht auf Anonymität. Das hat auch in täglichen Alltag eigentlich jeder. Das heißt, ich kann meine Meinung kundtun. Ich kann mich mit Leuten austauschen, ohne dass ich diesen Leuten meinen Namen verraten muss, ohne dass es einen Provider gibt, der mir diesen Austausch ermöglicht und der dazu Verkehrsdaten von mir vorhält. Und genau das muss eigentlich auch für das Internet gelten. Gerade noch mehr als für jedes andere Medium, weil das Internet eben auch global ermöglicht, dass Menschen sich untereinander austauschen und die demokratischen Prozesse darüber sehr stark gefördert werden. Das heißt, zum einen muss ein Recht auf Anonymität verankert werden und zum anderen muss auch verankert werden, dass eben Leute, die Anonymitätsdienste, wie das mit dem Tornetzwerk zum Beispiel ja gegeben ist, anbieten, dass diese Leute auch vor Repressalien durch den Staat geschützt werden.
Definiere mal Repressalien. Das finde ich bei dem Tornetzwerk halt immer spannend.
Eine Hausdurchsuchung war irgendwie das größte Problem. Wenn du eine Tor-Exit-Note betreibst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit recht hoch im Moment in Deutschland, dass du eines Tages Besuch von der Polizei erhältst und die bei dir alles, was irgendwie entfernt nach Computern aussieht, raustragen.
Was vom Prinzip ja schon zeigt, wie wenig überhaupt dieses ganze Vorgehen angepasste ist an die Realität. Wenn jemand einen Tor-Note betreibt, dann steht er nicht bei ihm im Wohnzimmer in der Regel und das bringt überhaupt nichts, die Wohnung zu durchsuchen und dort alle Computer mitzunehmen. Also das ist ja schon was, wo die Realität vollkommen entkoppelt ist, irgendwie von dem, wie man von staatlicher Seite davor geht. Aber es geht auch um Dinge wie Haftung oder den Haftungsausschluss eigentlich und eben das Recht, einen Anonymisierungsdienst anzubieten, ohne dafür haftbar zu sein, was mit diesem Anonymisierungsdienst dann im Endeffekt gemacht wird durch Dritte.
Also wir haben ja schon eine Sendung gehabt über WLAN gerade. Und das geht in dieselbe Richtung natürlich. Im Grunde möchten wir nicht, dass Leute belangt werden, weil sie ein offenes WLAN betreiben. Im Gegenteil.
Das sind Helden.
Denn die geben mir Internet, wenn ich verreist bin.
So, weiter geht's.
Genau, so der nächste Komplex, da geht's erstens um den Urheberrechtsschutz. Wir finden nämlich, der ist im Moment viel zu sehr ausgeufert. Im Moment ist es so, dass Leute regelmäßig von Abmahnungen und irgendwelchen Abmahnvereinen belästigt werden. Und dass da Grafen angedroht werden. Und die Musikindustrie da mit Fantasiezahlen operiert. Dass eine existenzielle Bedrohung für die Einzelnen daraus entsteht. Und deswegen finden wir, das muss mal entkernt und saniert werden. Und finden unter anderem, dass da eine Bagatellgrenze eingeführt gehört. Wenn irgendwelche Privatleute eine Urheberrechtsverletzung machen und da keinen kommerziellen Hintergrund hatten und keinen Vorteil daraus gezogen haben, dann wird das nicht verfolgt. Also wir finden, die Zahlen, die da hantiert werden, die sollten mal auf eine faktische Basis gestellt werden. Und wir brauchen sowas wie eine Bagatellgrenze in der Strafverfolgung. Und wir können eigentlich auch noch über ein paar andere Sachen nachdenken, aber das ist eine eigene Sendung.
Es ist ja sogar noch viel schlimmer, das hatten ja einige Publikationen auch auf Wikileaks zum Beispiel gezeigt, dass aus diesem ganzen Urheberrechtsschutz und Abmahnwahn eigentlich ein Geschäftsmodell gemacht wird. Und dass es mittlerweile ja lukrativer zu sein scheint, dass man eben jemanden verfolgt wegen einer Urheberrechtsverletzung als überhaupt das Material, was man verkaufen möchte, eben zu verkaufen. Und das ist ja schon vollkommen pervers an sich.
Genau, also wie viel Urheberrechtsschutz gehört revolutioniert, das muss mal komplett neu gemacht werden.
Ihr nehmt aber sozusagen auch in Kauf, da steckt schon noch so ein bisschen die politische Forderung dahinter, dass Urheberrechtsschutz für Privatleute eigentlich Unsinn ist und ihr denkt, das soll wirklich einfach jeder haben, was er will.
Na ganz so nicht. Aber wenn ich mir einen MP3 runterziehe, dann finde ich, dass der Aufwand für die Verfolgung übersteigt, die den Gewinn für die Gesellschaft durch die Verfolgung um ein Vielfaches. Und da muss irgendwo eine Grenze gezogen werden. Und also wenn jetzt jemand erwischt wird und er hat irgendwie zwei Terabyte MP3s dabei, dann ist die Grenze überschritten. Aber wenn jemand irgendwie mit einem MP3-Player herumläuft und da sind irgendwie ein paar Songs drauf, die er sich kopiert hat, na ja, mein Gott, na und?
Okay, wäre auch spannend, wo man diese Grenze dann zieht.
Genau, das ist eine andere Frage.
Jetzt würde ich gerne noch mal kurz an Andreas dazunehmen, weil das passiert nämlich viel zu selten. Er hat Erfahrung mit Internetzensur im Ausland. Hallo Andreas. Was genau ist dir denn passiert?
Ja, passiert also kurz im Hintergrund. Ich bin Service-Techniker und bin eigentlich 80 Prozent des Jahres nicht in Deutschland, sondern ja, in China, Russland, Japan und solchen Geschichten.
Ganz freie Länder.
Also in China ist zum Beispiel Folgendes passiert, ich sitze ganz normal im Hotel, Internet ist gratis, alles schön und gut. Wikipedia funktioniert einfach nicht. Das hat bis damals nicht funktioniert. Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Es kam einfach eine Blank-Seite.
Na ja, das haben wir ja auch manchmal.
Und ich möchte einfach nur so ein bisschen erzählen. Letzte Woche in Italien bin ich auf so eine sogenannte Stoppseite gestoßen. Da kommt dann irgendwie ein offizielles Logo von der Polizei und sagt, hier, da dürfen sie nicht drauf.
Cool, was war denn das, wo du denn hin wolltest?
Eine Pornseite natürlich. Also, ich meine, aber ich dachte, wir haben das nicht. Ich dachte, die EU diskutieren erst darüber und Italien macht das Einzelschaum.
Na ja, Berlusconi halt. Der macht ja noch ganz andere Sachen.
Ja, das ist auch, aber wenigstens konnte er seine Banken retten mit den 500-Euro-Scheinen. Na ja, anyway, und einfach, wie klingt es denn, was ich damit sagen möchte, ist was, was ich nicht verstehe. Ich meine, die Leute, die wissen, dass man diese technischen Sprechen machen kann, schön und gut. Da können sich vielleicht auch einige Leute mit abhalten davon, auf diese Seite zu kommen. Aber ich bin in China auf die Wikipedia-Seite gekommen. Ich bin auch in Italien auf meine Porno-Seite gekommen. Also mit ein bisschen Anleitung und Google-Fragen komme ich da doch immer wieder hin.
Der Punkt ist eigentlich ein anderer. Der Punkt ist, dass es alles näher als es für uns aussieht. Also nicht für uns vom CCC. Wir wissen ja, wie nah das ist. Deswegen kämpfen wir ja so laut dagegen. Aber die Normalbevölkerung denkt einfach, ach naja, wenn das so schlimm wäre, wie der CCC sagt, dann würde das schon nicht passieren. Weil wir hier in Deutschland, wir haben eine Demokratie bei uns, gibt sowas nicht. Ja, aber das ist einfach, die Leute realisieren es nicht und man muss einfach sagen, also es gibt andere Länder, wo du sowas erleben kannst, zum Beispiel den arabischen Raum, die haben auch weitgehende Internetzenso. Also das ist in der Tat in vielen Ländern der Welt ein echtes Problem, dass das Internet zensiert wird und das ist nicht nur eine theoretische Sache, wo der CCC aus ideologischen Erwägungen gegenkämpft, sondern das ist real.
Und in jedem Land hat halt seine Zerbute. In Deutschland zum Beispiel ist es unsere Vergangenheit. Das wird in Japan ganz anders gehandelt. Da kann ich ganz normal in ein Geschäft gehen und original SS-Uniformen kaufen. Das ist da überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Na ja, versuch mal in Japan Schamhaare zu finden. Schamhaare zu finden. Also das ist ja... Die Gesellschaft in Japan möchte ja gerne zensiert werden. Das ist noch mal so ein kulturelles Problem, was ja auch besteht. Hörst du dir das? Ja, natürlich. Also die meisten Japaner sehen das Internet als Bedrohung. Und dass es eben Dinge gibt, die ihre Kinder dort bedrohen und dass es am besten der Staat in irgendeiner Art und Weise regulieren muss.
Also ein guter Vater sitzt sich neben meinem Kind, wenn es am Computer sitzt.
Genau. Und das ist auch dein Bildungsauftrag nicht nur dem Kind gegenüber, sondern auch dem Rest der Welt gegenüber, dass du das erzählst. A, wie man Zensur umgeht, wenn man sie hat. Und B, dass das Aufpassen auf das eigene Kind der Weg ist, wie man Medienkompetenz vermittelt. Und nicht Zensieren vom Internet.
Solange mein Kind nicht 18 ist, habe ich auf mein Kind aufzupassen.
Genau. Weiter machen.
Ja, ich kann das vielleicht machen. Aber jetzt überleg doch mal. Die meisten Leute, die müssen inzwischen schon zwei Jobs haben. Und das geht nicht mehr mit denen. Also die können das nicht.
Da kann man sich ja eine Art Vierkraft einstellen dann. Ja, Witze ist immer einfach. Tut mir leid.
Da kommen wir wieder zum Punkt, dass 80 Prozent der Leute das vielleicht als Idee ganz gut finden, aber das praktisch gar nicht umsetzen können.
Das ist unser Auftrag, das zu ändern.
Da sind wir wieder bei der Bildung. Und ich fand es auch gerade spannend, das über Japan zu hören, weil ich mich das auch manchmal in Deutschland frage. Vielleicht wollen die Leute das ja einfach, dass das alles so schön sauber und abgekappt ist.
Wir wollen einfach, was du ihnen erzählst. Das nennt sich Perception-Management. Das ist aber auch eine eigene Sendung, oder?
Das ist auch eine eigene Sendung.
Wir haben bestimmt noch ein paar Thesen.
Wir machen noch ein paar Thesen. Wir haben jetzt noch 10 Minuten.
Wir machen einfach ganz schnell. Ganz, ganz schnell. Also die nächste These ist, dass EU-Richtlinien bitte, wenn sie schon erfüllt werden, dann als Schnittmenge erfüllt werden. Also wenn sich 10 Länder treffen, oder wie viele wir jetzt halt sind in der EU, wie viele sind wir, 23? Also wenn sich die EU mal wieder einigt, dass wir eine Cybercrime-Convention brauchen, dann soll bitte am Ende jedes Land die Schnittmenge implementieren und nicht jedes Land irgendwie, wozu sie gerade Bock haben. Bei uns ist das regelmäßig so, dass wir nicht nur alles implementieren, sondern noch darüber hinausgehen. Also unsere Regierung nutzt das dann als Vorwand, um Sachen, die sie vorher innenpolitisch nicht durchgekriegt haben, einfach trotzdem zu machen und lügen uns dann ins Gesicht, das sei notwendig, um die EU-Richtlinien zu erfüllen. Und das möchten wir gar nicht mehr.
Hast du gerade Vorratsdatenspeicher angesagt?
Aber das wäre ein Beispiel. Vielen Dank, dass du das angesprochen hast. So, die nächste These geht um Softwarepatente. Da sind wir nämlich auch dagegen. Und zwar nicht nur, weil wir persönlich in der Branche tätig sind, sondern weil Softwarepatente eben die Basis des Internets betreffen. Die Basis-Technologie im Internet. Und das sind inzwischen nicht nur Router und IP-Pakete, sondern das sind auch Sachen wie Video-Codecs. H264. Kann einer mal gugeln, was es da für Probleme gab mit H264 im Browser und warum Chrome und Google jetzt VP8 macht. Das ist alles eine unglaubliche Grütze mit den Software-Patenten. Wir haben die hier zwar theoretisch nicht, aber es gibt in Amerika welche und da sieht man, was das für Probleme hat, die auch uns hier betreffen. Und das braucht man alles nicht. Die müssen wir uns nicht geben, diese ganzen Probleme. Deswegen sollten wir nicht nur bei uns dafür sorgen, dass es keine Software-Patente gibt, sondern wir sollten die bereits erlassenden Software-Patente vom Europäischen Patentamt allesamt für ungültig erklären und festschreiben, dass es auch nie wieder Software-Patente gibt bei uns.
Wenn es gar keine gibt, wie konnten die denn erlassen werden?
Ja, das ganze Patentamt fragen, das verstehe ich auch nicht. Klingt für mich wie Widerspruch, ist aber so.
Okay, herzlich willkommen in der Patentpolitik.
Genau, da machen wir auch mal... Das Problem des Patentamt ist inzwischen ein sogenannter Profit Center. Die nehmen nämlich Geld pro Patentanmeldung und wenn die anfangen, zu viele Patente zurückzuweisen, haben die Angst, dass dann weniger neue reinkommen. Deswegen nehmen sie lieber mehr Patente, auch wenn die ungültig sind. Und die Firmen spekulieren darauf, dass die irgendwann gültig sind. Und dann müssen sie halt nicht mehr anstehen, um ihre Patente reinzukriegen, sondern die sind halt schon drin.
Wow, noch mal eine eigene Sendung.
Noch mal eine eigene Sendung, genau. So, die nächste These, der geht zum Haftung. Und zwar meinen wir damit erstens die Internetprovider. Also wenn ich meinen Blog irgendwo hoste, dann ist das meine Verantwortung und nicht die von meinem Provider. Und der Provider hat unter gar keinem Umstellen für irgendwelche Inhalte zu haften, die ich da reingestellt habe.
Und wenn du dein Blog hostest, bist du ja noch...
Wenn ich ein Blog hoste, wo auch andere Leute posten können, dann habe ich keine Verantwortung für die Sachen, die andere Leute bei mir reinstellen. Aber es gibt eine Take-down-Notice- und Take-down-Sache. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz, ganz gute Regelung. Wenn ich gegen irgendwas verstoße mit meinem Blog, weil irgendein Typ da was gepostet hat, und ich hab das noch nicht gesehen, oder es war mir nicht klar, dass das eine Verletzung ist, dann sagt man mir Bescheid und ich muss das dann zeitnah löschen. Und wenn ich das nicht tue, dann kann man drüber nachdenken, ob ich belangbar werde. Aber sobald dieses Damoklesschwert der Haftung über einem schwebt, ist das ein großer Hammer, der im Moment dafür sorgt, dass alle möglichen Geschichten einfach verschwinden. Auch der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk löscht gerne mal einfach Nachrichten aus den Archiven oder bei Tagesschau-Streams heißt es dann, aus rechtlichen Gründen darf dieser Teil nicht gesendet werden. Oder wenn Panorama mal wieder einen Beitrag gemacht hat, der übers Ziel hinausgeschossen ist, dann kommt die große Haftungskeule und dann rechnet sich eben NDR aus, naja, es ist jetzt billiger, das erstmal rauszunehmen und später kann man es ja wieder reinstellen. Aber das später wieder reinstellen gibt es halt nicht mehr, wenn wir auf sieben Tage limitieren. Also diese Haftungskeule ist im Moment der große, das große Damoklesschwert, mit der unter anderem die Urheberrechtssachen durchgeführt werden.
Also, aber um zusammenzufassen, es geht doch nicht um Verantwortungslosigkeit, sondern es geht darum, dass jeder nur für sein Zeug verantwortlich ist.
Genau, jeder haftet für das Zeug, was er gemacht hat und nicht für andere Leute Sachen. Denn wenn wir anfangen, den Internet-Providern Haftungen anzudrohen für Inhalte anderer Leute, dann werden sie einfach dafür sorgen, dass Sachen nicht mehr veröffentlicht werden, wenn irgendein Zweifel besteht. Und dann haben wir wieder eine Diktatur, das wollen wir nicht. Deswegen muss das von vorne rein vom Tisch, das ist im Moment eigentlich auch so geregelt. Aber wir möchten gern, dass es so bleibt, deswegen sagen wir das nochmal extra. So, jetzt haben wir eigentlich nur noch zwei Thesen, die uns wirklich wichtig waren. Wir haben nämlich die Rundfunkräte. Und zwar ist da der Punkt, dass der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk eine Quelle ist für Daten. Wir haben auf der einen Seite natürlich die privatwirtschaftlichen Verlage, die uns Zeitungen wie den Spiegel oder Tagespiegel oder was weiß ich publizieren. Da können wir unsere Daten herbeziehen. Oder wir können zum öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gehen. Und der hat im Moment den Auftrag, uns zu informieren. Und zwar unabhängig. Aber das hilft ja nicht, wenn ich eine Woche im Urlaub bin. Und während der Woche kann ich das nicht abrufen, weil es nämlich einen Filter auf das Land gibt. Und wenn ich zurückkomme, ist es nicht mehr im Archiv. Also wir finden...
Die sieben Tage ist nur ein Tagesaktuelles. Also die Verweildauer, so heißt es so schön, ist ein Jahr.
Ja, das hängt vom Inhalt ab.
Genau, das hängt vom Inhalt ab.
Genau, aber das ist doch scheiße.
Und warum überhaupt auch nur ein Jahr? Also warum wird das überhaupt begrenzt in Zeiten, in denen wir eigentlich speichern können, ohne dass uns der Platz ausgeht?
Das liegt ja nicht daran, dass es gewisse Leute gibt, die sagen, der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk hat im Netz nichts zu suchen. Also jetzt grob zusammengefasst.
Nein, aber das ist doch eine vollkommen unsinnige Argumentation. Ich bezahle doch mit meinen Steuergeldern, dass es diesen öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gibt. Und ich bin doch heute kein Konsument mehr, der mit seinem Weltempfänger zu Hause sitzt, sondern ich bin jemand, der primär das Internet benutzt. Und das ist doch eigentlich, wenn ich möchte, dass es diesen Rundfunk gibt, den öffentlich-rechtlichen, dann doch im Internet. Alles Weitere können wir von mir drüber reden, ob wir das noch brauchen in Zukunft.
Bis auf Radio, da brauchen wir zumindest am letzten Mittwoch im Monat mindestens einen Sender in Berlin. Aber abgesehen davon, wenn ich dafür bezahle, dass diese Inhalte gemacht werden und dass sie vorliegen, die liegen ja auch digital vor, dann möchte ich bitte, dass mit meinen Geldern auch dafür gesorgt wird, dass die für immer abrufbar sind. Also wenn irgendwie ein Blitz einschlägt und ein Erdbeben das Archiv frisst, okay, da kann man drüber reden. Aber es soll jeder irgendwie vertretbarer Aufwand getrieben werden, damit das im Internet verfügbar ist und bleibt.
Was haltet ihr von der Idee, dass der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk alle seine Inhalte unter eine Creative Commons-Lizenz stellt und damit quasi so eine Art Cloud-basierte Verteilung seiner Inhalte macht?
Das folgt ja aus dem anderen Ding, was wir gesagt haben, Sachen, die mit Steuergeldern finanziert werden. Das ist jetzt keine Steuergelder, aber mit öffentlichen Mitteln.
Wird sie dann bald.
Genau, das ist ja auch bald. Sie sind automatisch allgemein frei. Das finde ich auch nach wie vor.
Das finde ich auch.
Das gilt auch für Rundfunk natürlich. Und die Sachen sollen alle im Internet sein und bleiben. Und dazu gehört eben nicht nur, dass die Daten alle da sein sollen, sondern auch, dass wir uns an den Auftrag erinnern sollen von dem öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Und dass das Programm eben nicht wie im Moment von irgendwelchen Rundfunkgeräten überwacht wird, wo irgendwelche Leute drin sitzen, die ich nicht wählen kann, sondern die nach irgendwelchen Kriterien vergeben sind, völlig untransparent und wo im Grunde, also beim ZDF ist ja relativ offensichtlich gewesen, Klientelpolitik betrieben wird. Sondern das soll tatsächlich unabhängig sein. So, das war zu den Rundfunkgeräten. Und die letzte Forderung, die haben wir auch schon fast am Ende, richtig? Was?
Nein.
Eine haben wir noch.
IT-Großprojekte. Also wir hätten gerne, dass IT-Großprojekte tatsächlich mit Sachverstand gemacht werden und nicht als Förderprogramm wie im Moment. Im Moment ist es so, wenn die Regierung irgendwelche IT-Großprojekte macht, wie zum Beispiel Mautbrücken, dass sie dann eben nicht danach gehen, was sinnvoll und umsetzbar ist, sondern dass sie das größtmögliche Projekt sich überlegen, dann irgendwas von Exportschlagerfaseln und nicht danach gehen, ob das A sinnvoll, B bezahlbar und C eine Restwahrscheinlichkeit hat, dass es auch funktionieren kann. Und nicht nur bei IT-Großprojekten, auch bei Gesetzen hätten wir gerne, dass die Regierung vorher mal Experten fragt und dann auch auf die hört.
Es geht ja vor allem ums aufhören. Es wird ja genug nach Experten gefragt. Das haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal jetzt gehabt.
Wir werden auch immer wieder gern befragt, übrigens, aber man hört nicht auf uns.
Du wolltest doch die Geschichte zu diesem Punkt erzählen, die ich jetzt wirklich gerne noch hören würde. Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Hackertools, genau. Das war genau so ein Ding. Da sind wir, also der CCC, praktisch als Sachverständiger vorgeladen worden in einen Bundestagsausschuss. Da ging es um das Hackertool-Verbot und ich bin dahin gegangen für den CCC. Und wir wurden mit den Worten begrüßt. Herzlich willkommen, meine Damen und Herren. Vielen Dank, dass Sie noch mal gekommen sind, nachdem wir es schon die letzten drei Male ignoriert haben. Und da dachte ich so, das ist jetzt ein Witz, oder? Aber genau so war es. Da waren zwölf Sachverständige. Alle haben unisono gesagt, dieses Gesetz ist scheiße, macht es nicht, ihr macht euch lächerlich, alle lachen über euch und ihr werdet unsere Industrie kaputt machen. Haben alle gesagt, alle Sachverständigen haben es gesagt. Und die Politiker haben sie angehört und haben dann doch dafür gestimmt.
Gleich danach?
Ja, ziemlich direkt danach, klar. Also das ist ja nur ein Ausschuss, die machen ja nicht das Gesetz. Aber der Ausschuss schreibt dann ein Papier, da steht drin, das ist ein gutes Gesetz, stimmt dafür. Das geht dann an die Fraktionen. Und die stimmen dann halt nach Fraktionen. Das heißt, die Sachverständigen lädt man nur ein, damit ich nachher nicht sagen kann, aus Formgründen ist das Gesetz ungültig, denn da sind keine Sachverständigen befragt worden.
Ach, das gibt es eigentlich in der Verpflichtung aber in Deutschland.
Na klar, sonst würde ich es so nicht machen. Also die fragen Sachverständige und ignorieren das. Und zwar regelmäßig. Das ist kein Einzelfall, sondern das ist tatsächlich so gut wie immer so. Da werden Sachverständige eingeladen und das sind auch tatsächlich Sachverständige. Das wäre ja meine Idee gewesen, wenn ich irgendwie der Mafiaboss wäre, der hier seine Diktatur managen muss, dann hätte ich mir vorgestellt, dass ich da einfach irgendwelche Pfeifen einlade, die halt meine Meinung sind. Aber nein, die laden tatsächlich Sachverständige ein, die alle unisono dagegen sind, und dann machen sie es trotzdem. Und das kann ja mal nicht sein.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob man das jemals umsetzen könnte. Ich glaube es ja direkt nicht. Wir haben jetzt heute über Thesen gesprochen, wo du hast manchmal betont, dass das sozusagen eine persönliche Meinung ist, aber manchmal auch schon, dass mehrere Leute das so sehen. Wird es da noch so eine Art Paper, hätte ich jetzt beinahe gesagt, also irgendwie Internet abrufbar, die Thesen von CCC?
Genau, das ist der Plan, dass wir in naher Zukunft Zeiten haben, gesprochen wir in wahrer Politik. Ein paar Thesen, Politiken, veröffentlichten, klar. Und ja, also das ist erstmal nur ein Entwurf hier. Aber das wird es auch schriftlich geben. Und mit, ja, ihr werdet auch, wenn ihr Kommentare habt, könnt ihr die uns jetzt schon geben natürlich.
Im Blog zur Sendung auf chaosradio.de Da gibt es auch den Podcast imnächst. Ich danke euch fürs Husein. Fefe und Daniel waren heute hier zu Gast, um mal darüber zu sprechen, wie Netzpolitik in Deutschland aussehen sollte, nach Meinung des Chaos Computer Clubs. Nach uns folgen, wie jede Woche um diese Zeit, Smith und Smart und vorher, ich sag übrigens gerne, was die in der Sendung machen und die posten das normalerweise auch meistens, aber diese Woche haben sie es irgendwie total verpeilt. Ich kriege jetzt von draußen gerade Handzeichen. Ja guck doch mal, wir haben es noch eingeschrieben. Jetzt ist zu spät. Jetzt hören wir die Musik, die ich noch ausgesucht habe und die auch an... Ja, nachdem ich nachgefragt habe, oder was? Ja, guck doch mal richtig da.
Also pass auf.
Wir gehen jetzt einfach, überlassen euch diesen komischen Chaoten hier, die nicht wissen, wie das komische Gesicht... Wir gehen jetzt mal schnell. Smart hat mich geradezu verdonnert.